le 3 janvier 2020 sur le quai branly à
paris des policiers arrêtent cédric
souvient alors comme ça vous kiffez mais
plaisamment nos jours c'est votre
courageuse et juste vous avez
volontairement sur votre plateau
l'annoncé mal on savait même pas s'il
vous plaît ne fais pas mon scooter et
salma plaque est allé
au bout d'une dizaine de minutes cédric
chauvière rejoint son scooter
ces provocations pousse les policières
revenir vers lui
et à le plaquer au sol
[Musique]
à ce moment là un des policiers
réalisent deux prises d'étranglement la
première debout
la seconde au sol
les trois policiers le maintien est à
terre et l'un d'entre eux exercent une
forte pression sur le dos de cédric joue
via une minute et 45 secondes plus tard
son coeur s'arrête d'après un rapport
d'expertisé médicale sortie dans la
presse le 24 janvier les trois actions
successives des policiers sont
directement responsables de la mort de
cédric souviens à l'époque plusieurs
vidéos ont été publiées dans la presse
mais dans les images que nous avons
récupérés on peut entendre ces mots
[Rires]
selon les agents le bruit de la
circulation a couvert les cris de cédric
joue via mais cette vidéo et le son qui
l'accompagnent met à mal la version des
policiers d'après nos informations ces
images sont dans le dossier
d'instruction elle pourrait être
utilisée par la défense afin de
poursuivre les agents pour homicide
volontaire
c'est vrai choix difficile d'avoir un
surtout pour vous un bien sûr sauf à
imaginer seas mois difficiles à avoir
alors les ressentir à ce moment-là subir
ce qu'il a subi je pense que c'est plus
difficile que ce qu'on peut vivre
maintenant elle actuellement regardant
ça j'ai lu le rapport d'experts le
rapport d'expert quoi je les lui voyez
les images association forte quand tu
liras part d'experts de a à z d'accord
les 40 pages du rapport experts moi je
me suis effondrée parce que moi je suis
tombé dans la souffrance de mon fils je
l' ai vu partir bien sûr c'est pas grave
pour toi c'est pas grave sait-on jamais
cp non monsieur meurtrier comme ton pote
c'est tout monsieur mes mots je remets
pas en cause votre souffrance en tant
que parent mais moi les faits sont
avérés si si malheureusement la victime
ne commet pas un outrage et ne vient pas
provoquer les policiers
ça n'arrive sur mon peut arriver
comment arriver à la mort d'un homme
qui semble la nation elle est clair
c'est que la police doit se faire
insulter et on doit jamais rien faire si
on fait quelque chose il ya du gras mais
je suis désolé que je vais bien je vais
pas tomber dans la production contre
vous mais je regarde je regrette que
justement en tant que papa n'essayez pas
il ya quelques vous êtes une génération
monsieur où je sais que votre génération
respecter la maréchaussée les gendarmes
ça voulait dire quelque chose on résume
aujourd'hui maintenant le quotidien des
policiers c'est ça on peut plus
intervenir on se fait insulter on te
fait caillasser on se fait cracher
dessus et quand on interpelle on est les
vilains et bah ça n'honore du symbolisme
chine aujourd'hui qu'il a vis à vis des
suicidés depuis le début de l'année sont
pas si c'est le suicide est le but du
modèle fondé sur
les échos si c'est de la merde hui
connaissait pas de site vous rapporter
70 pour le jarret pas d'éducation vous
avez l'impression que les policiers vers
l'ensemble de mes collègues
en train de dire question je pense et il
entend dire que bien sûr i il cautionne
pas voilà le le fait qu'ils aient dit
guignera nous tout ça mais il ne peut
pas un aller jusqu'à il entraîner la
mort une volonté cyril d'intention
homicide malheureusement si une
intervention qui a mal tourné pour
l'instant il n'est pas démontré que les
collègues ont eu la volonté de doter la
vie à ce contrevenant et équipe qui peut
le penser vous rendez compte les
collègues si à chaque fois qu'ils se
font insulter
ni vous savez le nombre d' outrage qu'on
a le nombre d'interpellations qui a tous
les jours malheureusement metz a vu
arriver une intervention de police peut
malheureusement être mal maîtrisée comme
un chirurgien par le foie rate son
patient